heute gibt es so ein kleines mini video
und zwar zum thema koffein ich habe
nämlich vor sechs monaten koffein
komplett aus meinem leben gestrichen und
damit meine ich auch tein
burana irgendwelche energydrinks alles
wo so künstliche wachmacher drin sind
oder natürliche aber die einen künstlich
wach machen auf instagram wollte ich von
euch wissen ob es ein paar fragen zu dem
thema gibt und ja es gibt ein paar
fragen zu dem thema ich hoffe dass ich
ein paar davon beantworten kann denn es
sind wirklich sehr viele jetzt geworden
ich denke aber am besten wäre es wenn
ich einfach schon mal erzählen warum
habe ich koffein abgesetzt was ist denn
da mit mir los gewesen es ist ja kein
geheimnis mehr dass ich unter
panikattacken leide manchmal sehr
schlimm manchmal ein bisschen weniger
aber grundsätzlich habe ich immer ein
gesundes level an anxiety in mir gehabt
dass mich sehr unruhig
meinen alltag bewältigen ließ so kann
man das am besten beschreiben also alles
was ich getan habe passierte mit einer
unruhe alle schönen dinge wurden immer
so ein bisschen versaut weil ich mir zu
viele gedanken darüber gemacht habe über
all die schlimmen möglichen folgen die
eine aktion mit sich tragen kann keine
ahnung man fährt in den urlaub und oh
mein gott was ist wenn ich auf dem weg
aufs klo muss oder was ist wenn unser
keine ahnung unser bus jetzt irgendwie
stehen bleibt auf dem weg zum hotel also
sowie die bescheuerten ängste die man so
haben kann und große ängste auch wie zum
beispiel habe ich einen herzinfarkt oder
habe ich vielleicht eigentlich für ein
tumor weil ich hatte jetzt zwei tage
kopfschmerzen solche sachen haben mich
immer herumgeplagt und durch hypnose
therapie und gesprächstherapie und
dieses buch was ich immer noch sehr
gerne empfehlen die antenne deine seele
will frei sein auf deutsch habe ich
wirklich meine ängste so weit im griff
bekommen das ich realistisch
realistisch damit umgehen konnte so war
es aber dann doch dass ich immer wieder
in unregelmäßigen abständen ein sehr
unangenehmes ängstliches gefühl in mir
hatte dass eine enge brust war und mich
irgendwie schlecht atmen ließ sehr
schwer nur sehr unkontrolliert also
wirklich diesen tiefen
diesen tiefen ruhigen atemzug konnte ich
nicht mehr wirklich machen das war ein
sehr dünnes atmen und so das stresslevel
war einfach mal sehr hoch ist der hat
mich glaube nicht so dieses cortisol
level was man dann immer hat das war bei
mir doch immer sehr sehr hoch und dann
bin ich vor einem halben jahr im sommer
auf ein video ich versuche es mal
rauszusuchen das verlinkt ich euch dann
auf ein video gestoßen zum thema koffein
und was es mit ängsten und depressionen
also wo steht da der zusammenhang jetzt
muss ich an dieser stelle sagen ich bin
kein arzt ich bin kein mediziner ich
habe das wieder studiert noch irgendwas
in dieser richtung gemacht das ist eine
ganz subjektive persönliche meinung das
ist aus meiner sicht so und wie ich die
fakten jetzt wieder gäbe ist auch nicht
mit
entsprechenden quellen und und so das
ist jetzt kein ressort video ich
verstehe jetzt nicht koffein ich will
euch einfach nur von meiner erfahrung
erzählen auf jeden fall wurde in diesem
video dann gesagt dass es eine
verbindung gibt durch studien eine
verbindung gibt zwischen koffein und
angst und depressionen panikattacken
diese ganze geschichte und das lag oder
liegt daran dass wir ja diese rezeptoren
im hirn haben soll und an diesen
rezeptor hängt sich dann koffein so und
das verhindert dass dieses
melatonin andere hormone es gibt viele
hormone die ein schläfrig werden lassen
dass sich dieses daran das ist dann mit
koffein da da ist dann schon was das
heißt wir bleiben was
eine lüge oder als ein missverständnis
ist dass man denkt dass koffein dich
wach macht das stimmt nicht also dieser
typische erste kaffee am morgen das ist
glaube ich sehr psychisch dass man denkt
dass man dadurch wach wird weil der
körper wird auch mit einem glas wasser
wach koffein sorgt eigentlich dafür dass
man auf irgendeiner position wach bleibt
und diese schlaf hormone diese
beruhigungs form ohne diese entspann
dich mal hormone gehen dann nicht an die
rezeptoren weil dann ist da koffein und
wir sind total
so
und meines wissens ist
nichts nichts unterschrieben
und man sagt auch beziehungsweise ist es
halt einerseits diese schlafraum ohne
müdigkeit hormone die dadurch blockiert
werden was ja dann diesen effekt hat
aber es gibt auch so also das ist auch
nicht alles sehr diese beruhigungs
hormone so diese ich entspanne dich mal
hormone und die können dann auch nicht
mehr ran das heißt wenn man stress hat
schafft es der körper nicht so gut
sich wieder zu beruhigen und zu sagen ne
hier steigt aus level an stress an
cortisol oder sonst was jetzt beruhigen
wir mal da da hinterher rein so ja und
das klang für mich absolut logisch weil
ich gemerkt habe ich bin jemand der
läuft mit seinem fast rum wie wir alle
aber mein fass hat so ein stress so ein
grund stresslevel
das ist das ist immer so voll das heißt
ich brauche nur ein ganz bisschen bis
dieses fast dann über läuft deswegen
vermutlich auch dass es leute da draußen
gibt die richtig viel stress ab können
was ja unsere gesellschaft mit applaus
belohnt und das ist ja ganz toll du
läufst mit einem leeren fass rum da die
kann die ganze zeit stress reinfallen
juckt niemanden dich selber sowieso
nicht weil das passt ja im noch nicht
über gelaufen so du hältst es aus ja und
dann gibt's halt leute wie mich die mit
so einem fast rum laufen was schon immer
eh schon so ein bisschen volles die
gründe könnte ich euch jetzt nennen ist
ganz schön persönlich und privat viele
dinge vielleicht werde ich euch mal
davon erzählen aber manche sachen sind
vielleicht auch einfach nur genetisch
dass ich ein mensch bin der nicht so
viel stress kann naja und durch das
koffein hatte ich das gefühl dass dieses
stress ding nicht so richtig sich
abgebaut hat das meer also das im alltag
dinge rein kommen können und das
stresslevel winkt immer so ein bisschen
das da halt wieder was rein kann und
dass ich mich aber immer noch
ausgeglichen fühle und das gefühl habe
mit dem alltag gerade klarzukommen und
seit ich das koffein abgesetzt habe ist
genau das eingetreten ich habe das
gefühl dieses stresslevel mit dem
fassbar womit ich eh den ganzen tag
rumlaufe sinkt so sehr dass mehr sachen
reinkommen können und ich trotzdem da
noch stehe und sage ja alles noch ganz
okay also ich fühle mich super ja und
das ist ungefähr das was mit mir den
letzten sechs monaten passiert ist also
ich bin wirklich seit der ersten woche
und ich kann mich daran so gut erinnern
weil ich immer noch zu timo am anfang
meinte
kannst du das glauben mir geht es seit
zwei wochen wirklich gerade gut oder
nach drei wochen kann sonst die augen
wie geht es nach drei wochen immer noch
also gut ich habe keine ängste nichts
und wir waren beide so echt so
überraschend und so positiv einfach
darüber dass diese kleinen veränderung
eigentlich nur koffein aus meinem leben
rauszuschmeißen dass das einfach mich
sehr ausgeglichen gemacht hat ich hatte
in den ersten zwei wochen wirklich noch
so phasen wo ich gemerkt habe so
ruhiger tag ist aber irgendwie
anstrengender so vom müdigkeitswarner
habe ich aber und jetzt kommt ein
kleiner tipp dann habe ich mich kurz
mittags hingelegt ich weiß es nicht in
allen berufsgruppen möglich aber wenn es
möglich für euch ist versucht meine
halbe stunde nicht gleich hin zu machen
wow das hat sich angefühlt wie ein café
weil ich meinem körper das gegeben habe
was er möchte einfach mal eine kurze
pause einfach mal kurz die augen
schließen nicht die ganze dorf den
bildschirm starren und so habe ich dann
geschafft also die ersten drei wochen
sind dann auch so verlaufen dass ich
mich da ab und zu mal hingelegt habe
weil ich müde war und
danach
gegen dieses möglichkeit gefühle auch
weg also ich trinke ich konsumiere kein
koffein vielleicht mal durch ein stück
dunkle schokolade dass da es ja glaube
ich auch ein bisschen koffein drin aber
ich konsumiere sonst kein koffein und
ich bin den ganzen tag wach konzentriert
was ich jetzt nicht mehr machen kann es
vielleicht abends noch irgendwie zwei
stunden für eine klausur pauken weil ich
meinen kaffee nicht reingezogen habe
aber
das ist ehrlich gesagt also bei mir
jetzt nicht so schlimm aber es ist halt
auch also ich hab n ergie so ich bin
nicht müde ich habe keinen mittags der
hänger also das habe ich sowieso gar
nicht mehr in mittags sänger ich hab
auch und das hatte ich schon gelesen
dass jemand gefragt hat ob ich
heißhunger seitdem habe und tatsächlich
nein ich kenne kein heißhunger mehr ich
weiß nicht inwiefern das mit koffein zu
tun haben kann das könnte ja mal die
kommentare schreiben falls ihr euch
damit auskennt aber ja das kann und ich
befinde mich gerade in alt also wir sind
jetzt gerade eigentlich auch intel viele
wegen vanessa nimmt ab da sich hier auf
einem kanal und
ich nehme also mir fest sehr leicht mich
zusammen zu ernähren und ich habe auch
keine heißhungerattacken ganz viele von
euch aber auch gefragt was ich denn
jetzt statt kaffee trinke und die
antwort ist ich trinke kaffee ich trinke
halt entkoffeinierten kaffee es gibt
einen kombinierten café in allen
restaurants bars cafés in denen ich bis
jetzt war
im supermarkt gibt es diese kleinen
kapseln für diesen espressomaschine in
koffein frei ich hole die ab und zu mal
von starbucks
aber wir sind mit 350 finde ich echt
schon sehr teuer ich glaube von lars
oder so gibt es auf jeweils gibt es gibt
oder zum teil meyer es gibt auf jeden
fall immer eine ent kombinierte variante
auch bei starbucks und
damit fahre ich super ich trinke aber
meine drei tassen kaffee am tag einfach
aus purer gewohnheit ich weiß nicht
warum ich das nicht mehr nicht also ich
kann das kann ich absetzen weil ich
stehe morgens auf trinken das floß am
schein auch sehr gut für die verdauung
mehr durch das gibt's bei dm mit so
orangengeschmack seitdem habe ich die
beste versorgung meines lebens dann
trinke ich so ein bisschen wasser und
dann mache ich mir schon mein kaffee und
dann mache ich mir eine stunde später
schon den nächsten café und mittags dann
noch mal einen kaffee aber halt ohne
koffein aber es schmeckt mir ich mag
café ich mag den geschmack und an t ja
natürlich ich kann jetzt keinen schwarz
thema trinken bubble tea fällt leider
raus also auch aus meinem lieblings
bubble tea laden kann ich jetzt kein
thema trinken weil sie kein einziges
produkt dort haben ohne koffein und das
finde ich auch ein bisschen das fand ich
ist das mich sehr traurig also sind
schön bammel tdm vermisse ich dann doch
ja aber es gibt räume steht es gibt
kräutertees es gibt früchtetees
räume steht räuber steht ganz viele euro
steht in allen geschmacksvariationen
räubers t orange karamell das ist mein
neuer lieblingsclub übrigens ja und so
werk stelle ich den alltag und jetzt
könnt ihr jetzt könnt ihr natürlich
fragen ja aber vanessa ich kann das
niemals ich kann
nicht auf koffein ich kann nicht auf
kaffee verzichten ich kann nicht auf
meinen schwarztee verzichten da könnte
ich sie vielleicht nochmal zurückrufen
weil ich drehe gerade nochmal kurzen
video ab kleiner kleiner anruf
dazwischen wo war ich und jetzt ist
wahrscheinlich die einen oder anderen
die sagen aber wenn es ich kann nicht
auf meinen schwarztee um einen kaffee
mein koffein verzichten weil ich
brauchte es weil ich es immer schon so
war wenn ihr das wirklich glaubt dann
sind eure probleme die das koffein
auslösen könnten nicht so groß weil mein
meine lebensqualität war so
eingeschränkt dass ich an dem punkt
alles ausprobiert hätte um dieses
problem zu lösen also meine meine city
hat mich so sehr beeinträchtigt und
genervt dass keine ahnung man hat mir
sagen können schneide dir ne glatze und
dann gegeben deine probleme weg hätte
ich gemacht ohne ohne mit dazu zogen
entzugserscheinungen hatte ich keine es
könnte ja zu kopfschmerzen kommen dass
es bei mir gar nicht aufgetaucht nur
müdigkeit wie geht es dir psychisch mir
geht es psychisch wunderbar also ich
glaube ich habe auch alles soweit
beantwortet ich würde halt nie wieder
zurück gehen also ich hole mir selbst
koffeinfreie cola und trinke
koffeinfreie cola und ich fühle mich
sehr gut mit ich bis jetzt nicht warum
ich noch mal mit graffin anfang sollte
weil der grund von koffein ist ja
eigentlich dieses wachbleiben wach
machen und das bin ich ja ich bin ja die
ganze zeit wach ohne koffein und das ist
ja eigentlich der normalzustand ich
meinen kumpels kinder die trinken auch
kein koffein den ganzen tag und die sind
sehr wach und es gibt sehr viele
probleme so was wie zb schlafstörungen
an denen so viele menschen leiden die
aber vielleicht noch um 16 uhr im café
trinken ja
ein gewinn sondern erstmal das
offensichtlichste rausschneiden und dann
sieht man wie es einem geht und das
passt schon zu dem thema ich sehe meine
akkus gerade alle gegangenen
kopfschmerzen manche leute haben ja so
geschrieben dass ihre migräne dadurch
weg gegangen ist einige trinken ja
kaffee bei migräne oder koffein damit
die kopfschmerzen weg gehen andere sagen
keine migräne mehr sein können kaffee
kein gummi gesellschaftlich hat sich für
mich auch nichts geändert ich bin immer
noch unterwegs ich kann immer noch
kaffee trinken denn jedes restaurant hat
cobra wie
energy-drinks die fallen halt raus aber
ganz ehrlich ich fand es dieses gefühl
nicht nach einem energy drink da hat
mein herz geflattert und ich habe mich
nicht gut gefühlt ich fühle mich
wirklich fantastisch mir geht es
wirklich sehr sehr gut seit ich das
koffein rausgehalten habe aus meinem
leben und das ist sechs monate jetzt her
und ich nehme halt immer meinen
alternativen kubin freien kaffee das
schmeckt ganz genauso
falls sie noch fragen habt stationen in
die kommentare redet vielleicht in den
kommentaren darüber und wir sehen uns
dann wiese wieder dann
aber diese anrufe den ich bekommen der
ist jetzt wirklich wichtig ich habe
persönliche sachen wenn ich davon
erzählt wir sehen uns